érzem én is a piacon hogy szinte
büntetve vannak a a fiatal hölgyek tehát
félnek bevallani hogy szeretnének
gyereket vállalni mert lehet hogy akkor
nem alkalmazzák vagy nem kapnak
fizetésemelést ha ma büntetem a
munkatársamat amiatt mert mert gyermeket
vállal akkor ne csodálkozzak hogy 10 év
múlva sokkal kevesebb gyermek fog
születni amit jutalmazunk az növekszik
és amit büntetünk az az az viszont
csökken abszolút van relevancia
egyébként én is azt látom és talán a
vállalkozoktól a legnagyobb tehát
szerintem a legnagyobb akodal az a
félelem hogy akkor most most elmegy és
hogy fogik pótolni vagy kénymetlen
kényelmetlen meg meg ki kell képezni új
embert rá de de pont ez hogyha egy picit
nem fáj akkor nincs fejlődés és nem is
tudom már ki mondta de de ez a nagy
igazság hogyha hogyha benne vagy
két-három évig a vállalkozásodban é úgy
kényelmes meg minden akkor akkor az nem
jó